JEANNE MOOS: This may look
like a decorative dog standing
amid five Halloween
decoration cats,
but the dog is real, a Lab
by the name of Maverick.
ADAM FLORES: He was
just like, frozen.
I mean, it's like somebody
just like, frozen in place.
JEANNE MOOS: Maverick's
owner, Adam Flores,
says it was the first
time the dog saw the cats.
He stopped in his tracks--
[LAUGHING]
JEANNE MOOS: --in their South
Texas front yard as Adam,
his wife, and even his
5-year-old daughter cracked up.
ADAM FLORES: Maverick
[LAUGHING]
JEANNE MOOS: He looks
like you paused him,
commented one TikToker.
Joked another, I think
your dog is broken.
To do a hard reset,
refer to owner's manual.
ADAM FLORES: Hey come on, Mav.
JEANNE MOOS: It was as
if Maverick was trapped
in that old Gloria Gaynor song.
[MUSIC - GLORIA GAYNOR, "I WILL
SURVIVE"] At first I afraid,
I was petrified
JEANNE MOOS: And only after
more than a minute of paralysis
did Adam manage to
break the spell.
ADAM FLORES: Hey.
It's OK, dude.
JEANNE MOOS: His catatonic
tail woke up first.
Someone pointed out, Lab
thinks he's a pointer.
So we showed the
video to Justin McGill
who breeds Pointing Labs at
Hunters Point Kennel in Iowa.
Was Maverick pointing,
or was he petrified?
JUSTIN MCGILL: Oh no,
hell he was pointing.
He wasn't scared.
His body language,
his tail was medium.
He wasn't tucked
between his legs.
He didn't have any
control over that,
that's just total instinct.
He walked out the door,
saw that and locked up.
JEANNE MOOS: Unlike
an English Pointer,
Labs are not known as pretty
pointers when they spot prey.
JUSTIN MCGILL: Oh,
yeah, it's ugly as hell.
JEANNE MOOS: Nevertheless--
what do you say to people
that say labs don't point?
JUSTIN MCGILL: [MUTED]
Come up and see my kennel.
JEANNE MOOS: The point is, don't
call Maverick a scaredy cat.
Jeanne Moos, CNN.
ADAM FLORES: It's OK, dude.
JEANNE MOOS: New York
ADAM FLORES: Come on.